merci d'être là fabrizzio nelson groupe
ebra un les journaux régionaux de l'est
de la france
il y aura une réécriture complète de
l'article 24 de la loi sur la sécurité
globale c'est en tout cas ce que disent
en choeur les députés de la majorité
présidentielle on les a vus hier a
emmené notamment par christophe castaner
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé
sébastien chenu il ya soulevé dans cette
affaire là il ya le fond et la forme
et j'allais dire des deux côtés la
majorité s'est pris les pieds dans le
tapis
d'abord écrire un article qui a été
votée c'est assez inédit la république
en marche fait preuve
j'allais dire de d'audace puisqu'elle
traite le parlement d'une façon un peu
originale puisqu'elle fait voter une
proposition de loi qui vient de ces de
ses troupes et ensuite elle demande de
réécrire l'article donc on sait très
bien que tout ça n'est pas très sérieux
oui moi j'ai voté et l'article et la
proposition de loi parce que j'ai
considéré et finalement on vient sur le
fond la forme d'abord une question sur
la forme à dire qu'on va réécrire un
article qui doit passer au sénat qui
doit être examiné par le sénat
est ce que pour vous c'est possible
enfin c'est pas possible c'est du jamais
vu
et j'allais dire la majorité nous montre
l'étendue de sa nullité en ce qui
concerne ça fait trois ans et demi qe
cents à faire son incapacité même à
écrire une simple proposition de loi ils
en sont même pas capables le problème
c'est que c'est quand même sur la
sécurité des français
cette proposition de loi dont elle dont
elle fait l'objet on parle d'un sujet
tout à fait sérieux la majorité n'est
donc pas capable d'écrire une
proposition de loi pour protéger les
français
j'arrive pas à comprendre henin n'est
pas capable et vous avez quand même
voter non mais parce que nous l'article
nous semblait tout à fait clair mais ce
sont eux qui nous disent que finalement
il faut le réécrire enfin fallait
l'écrire avant falaise avec l'avant nous
nous avons voté un article
c'est ça oui oui nous aller mais parce
que et je viens sur le fond en fait
c'est une toute petite loi ce que nous
avons voté c'est une petite oie qui ne
règle pas le problème de la sécurité des
français dans notre pays c'est une loi
qui permette de donner quelques pouvoirs
supplémentaires et une organisation un
peu différente à la police municipale
c'est une loi qui permet de protéger un
peu les forces de l'ordre lorsqu'elles
sont jetés en pâture sur les réseaux
sociaux ça c'est l'article 24
c'est une loi qui parlait de sécurité
prix
ce sont des petits dispositif qui permet
d'améliorer les choses et nous ne sommes
pas des gens secteur on s'est dit si
tous ces dispositifs techniques n'est
pas dans une grande loi de sécurité
permettent d'améliorer un peu le
quotidien des forces de l'ordre et des
polices municipales
on va la voter on ne voyait pas de
difficulté est aujourd'hui la majorité
est sens dessus dessous
parce qu'il ya eu cette manifestation
aussi de samedi parce que la moitié de
la majorité est hostile finalement à cet
article 24 parce que je crois que c'est
la limite en fait dû en même temps en
matière de sécurité
vous ne comprenez pas le malaise qu'a
suscité cet article ah non pas du tout
parce qu'en fait cette loi ne permet pas
de va ne limite pas les pouvoirs et les
possibilités qu à la presse de faire son
travail on peut continuer à filmer les
gens à diffuser je note d'ailleurs et
c'est assez quand même perturbant que
ceux qui sont floutés dernièrement sur
les images ce sont les délinquants
samedi les gens qui étaient floutés sur
les images c'était les délinquants qui
cassaient les vitrines à bordeaux à
paris ont toutes leur visage
il n'y a pas de problème les policiers
qui vont se retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux et leur adresse leur nom et c
c'est-à-dire avec une volonté derrière
malveillantes
e on viendrait dire bah non il faut pas
l'écouter il faut les laisser tel quel
on voit bien vu une incompréhension
autour de cet article 24 est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas fallu s qu'ils n'ont pas eu
raison de l'entendre cette cette
incompréhension et du coup de
retravailler cet article le problème si
vous laissez qui a pas de stratégie en
fait derrière tout ça ce que ce sont des
propositions qui sont faites presque
sous le coup de l'émotion
il n'y a pas de vision de la façon dont
il faudrait protéger nos compatriotes
dans ce pays on le sait bien emmanuel
macron n'a aucune aucun tropisme pour le
régalien c'est à dire pour les sujets
comme ceux de la sécurité publique
la capacité à protéger les français
c'est pas du tout son truc
ils ont fait monter gérald darmanin je
veux dire de façon tout à fait
cosmétiques en disant voilà il vient de
la droite il va aller parler à la droite
il va être celui qui montre les muscles
le problème c'est que c'est facile de
montrer les muscles dans un hémicycle à
l'assemblée la réalité c'est lorsqu'il
s'agit de faire des lois parce qu'il
s'agit de donner des moyens lorsqu'il
s'agit d'avoir une volonté politique
il est lâché en rase campagne gérald
darmanin cause des cosmétiques pour vous
gérald darmanin mini sabato totalement
où sont les nouveaux moyens qui sont les
gens qui ont été arrêtés samedi
les black blocks les fameux black blocks
dont tous les syndicats de police nous
disent qu'ils sont parfaitement
identifiés mais sont pas arrêtés où les
corps on se souvient qu'un étroit qui
ont été en comparution immédiate
on attend de savoir à quoi ils seront
condamnés qui dormira en prison vous les
comptes rappelle le nombre de gilets
jaunes qui ont été arrêtés le nombre de
sacs à main et de sacs à dos de gilets
jaunes qui étaient fouillés de façon
préventive avant les manifestations
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un problème
il n'y a pas de volonté politique de
s'attaquer à l'insécurité
moi je me pose même la question de
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on laisse les
black blocks venir tout casser et
discréditer un certain nombre de
manifestations
moi je pense que nous pouvons les laisse
sont les la williams on les a si on les
identifions des assignés à résidence
voyez où par exemple ce qu'ont fait les
britanniques résidant tous les syndicats
de police vous disent qu'ils sont
parfaitement identifiés ce sont toujours
les mêmes les black blocks et pas des
gens qui arrivent de la planète mars ce
sont des gens qui sont parfaitement
identifiés qui s'infiltrent qui viennent
de l'extrême gauche qui sont dans des
réseaux d'extrême gauche qui sont sur la
toile et ce sont des gens qui sont
identifiés parce que à force d'être
alpagué après les manifestations on à
leur identité et bien les assigne à
résidence qu'elle est là les
britanniques ont laissé courir alors eh
bien ça permet en réalité en ne faisant
rien ça discrédite bien souvent des
manifestations et moi je me demande si
l'idée de devoir des manifestations l'a
vu avec les gilets jaunes la réforme des
retraites etc
la discréditer des manifestations au
fond le gouvernement ne se dit pas comme
ça il y aura un peu moins de
manifestation si les gens se rendent
compte que ce sont des endroits où ça va
chauffer taper etc
j'aimerais qu'une stratégie pour
protéger les français
mais on ne la voit pas et d'upi gérald
darmanin et là on ne voit pas de
stratégie la chaîne pénale
depuis dupond-moretti là c'est toujours
pareil on va libérer davantage de
prisonniers encore cette année c'était
un contrôleur général des prisons
d'ailleurs qui incite aux libérations
deux prisonniers en grand nombre je
crois que vraiment ce gouvernement a un
problème en ce qui concerne la capacité
à protéger au sens large des français on
l'a vu sur la sécurité sanitaire anses a
été incapable de protéger les français
on le voit en matière économique il
laisse crever les commerces de proximité
en tous les cas il ne les accompagne pas
les propositions à son bureaucratique
elles sont mal calibré ils sont mal
adaptés qui en matière de sécurité
eh bien il laisse les français
confrontés au pire d insécurité dont il
faut bien rappeler toujours ce sont les
plus modestes les plus pauvres qui
souffrent de l'insécurité en premiers
mois je suis député d'une
circonscription les plus pauvres de
france
il ya de l'insécurité dans un certain
nombre de villes de ma circonscription
ce sont les populations les plus
modestes à douchy-les-mines à denain
escaudain qui s'ouvre avec des parfois
des municipalités faut le rappeler
qu'ils ne veulent pas créer de police
municipale par dogmatisme idéologique il
y à des municipalités
vous êtes favorable au transfert de sa
tante de compétences vers les polices
municipales c'est rien c'est régaliennes
oui je pense que c'est un complément
tess et une complémentarité nécessaire
la police municipale et moi je pense
qu'il faut que la police municipale soit
formé on a proposé voyez-vous avec
marine le pen dans ce débat la création
d'une école de la police municipale pour
mieux former les gens également parce
que quand on est mieux formés on peut
avoir une mobilité qui est plus
importante qui est plus adapté ça a été
rejetée par le gouvernement alors que
cette proposition
elle était même dans le rapport
fauvergue et qui est à l'initiative de
la proposition de loi on a fait des
propositions très concrètes pour
améliorer la vie de nos compatriotes
parce que je pense que nous avons une
vision d'ensemble de ce qu'il faut faire
pour protéger les français
ce gouvernement les bateaux vont vite ça
vous entendez françois baroin quel
président de l'association des maires de
france qui dit non mais les maires ils
sont pas là pour assurer la police
municipale donc les maires ne sont pas
là pour assurer leur public ils sont ni
la sécurité publique ils sont là pour
assurer la tranquillité publique il ne
faut pas faire peser sur les épaules de
la police municipale des responsabilités
qu'ils doivent peser sur les épaules de
la police nationale vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec raison aux raisons pour
laquelle je pense que c'est une
complémentarité nécessaire la police
nationale d'avoir des moyens doit être
équipée doit être soutenue d'avoir des
missions très clair et la police
municipale en complémentarité de pouvoir
l'accompagner
justement pour gérer la tranquillité
publique ne gère pas la tranquillité
publique sans moyens sans homme sans
compétence sans capacité parfois
contrôle et des autres
un peu lisse mines moi je pense que la
police municipale doit être armés je
pense que ça la protège
je pense que ça lui donne une force et
un statut d'autorité dont elle a besoin
vous savez la délinquance elle a
terriblement évolué ces dernières années
la violence qu'on connaît dans nos
villes est extrêmement forte et vous ne
faites pas renier la tranquillité
publique simplement gérald harman a eu
raison de laisser la main aux maires sur
l'armement des normes je pense que ça
doit être un armement l'armement doit
être obligatoire il doit bien entendu
être assortie d'une formation
extrêmement précises extrêmement
sérieuse ce ne sont pas des sous
policiers
les policiers municipaux riou c'est
aussi ça je pense qu'il faut
rééquilibrer c'est le regard qui est
porté sur eux souvent on les regarde et
la majorité les regarde comme des sous
policiers
moi j'ai beaucoup de reconnaissance pour
les policiers municipaux parce que
souvent ils sont confrontés les premiers
aux vraies difficultés et on l'a vu
notamment à nice l'armement dans
l'espace public des policiers nationaux
pardon en dehors des périodes de service
pour vous c'est l'article 25 pour vous
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne oui
d'ailleurs il n'a pas créé beaucoup de
difficultés dans le débat je crois qu'il
ya une belle unanimité vous savez on se
souvient tous de magnanville de ces
policiers assassinés chez eux le fait
que les forces de l'ordre puissent
rentrer avec leurs armes chez eux dans
leur vie privée
parce qu'ils sont identifiés à
l'extérieur de leur commissariat comme
étant des forces de l'ordre est une
nécessité aujourd'hui je pense que cet
article d'ailleurs il n'a pas fait
l'objet ses deux fils d'armes dans
l'espace public
non c'est mieux d'armes vous savez plus
en plus d'armes vous les avez
dans les caves d'un certain nombre de
banlieue ensemble voilà je pense qu il
faut que la police soit armés et formés
c'est aussi ce qui empêchera la police
d'être mise à l'index
à partir du moment où il sera à la fois
respecté parce qu'on saura quels efforts
mais qu'elle est là pour protéger et ce
qui empêchera la police parfois de
pouvoir avoir peur parce que là les
policiers aussi peuvent avoir peur
devant des situations dans lequel il se
trouve vraiment très désarmé au sens
propre du terme en est justement vous
avez entendu gérald darmanin hier
inquiète auditionné pendant près de
trois heures par la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale il vous a
convaincu le ministre de l'intérieur non
je dois dire que vous savez c'est
beaucoup de redites les par exemple les
moyens dont par gérald darmanin se sont
déjà ce dont parlait christophe castaner
et qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé que s'est
il passé depuis
enfin ses moyens on va mettre combien de
temps à équiper en caméra piétons nos
policiers
on a le sentiment vraiment qu'il y a un
blocage qui lie à une absence de volonté
et qu'on tourne en rond gérald darmanin
nous refait exactement le même discours
que christophe castaner que de temps
perdu sincèrement c'est pas un bon
ministre de l'intérieur pour vous le
connaissez bien gérald darmanin drugs la
même région
vous venez de la droite tous les deux
oui je crois que gérald darmanin
je ne dis pas d'ailleurs je
vais pas lui faire un procès qui ne
serait pas juste mais je pense qu'il n'a
pas de il n'a pas de soutien politique
il a été mis là parce que justement il
vient de la droite on s'est dit il faut
un type de droite pour gérer la sécurité
des français
mais finalement il applique à ses
docilement la politique d' emmanuel
macron il est son ministre de
l'intérieur est finalement partie de moi
ya pas de volonté à l'étagé supérieur
gérald darmanin cette politique est une
politique sécuritaire à une politique de
défense des forces de l'ordre vous
l'approuvez pas je peux pas dire en tous
les cas que c'est une politique
sécuritaire dans le sens où je vois le
nombre de crimes et délits qui augmente
chaque année
et en face le nombre de policiers qui
sont dans des situations de détresse
absolue le bazar incroyable le chaos que
subit chaque semaine notre pays ce
désordre manifeste non je ne crois pas
que le gouvernement mène une politique
sécuritaire je pense que c'est la
politique du désordre
le gouvernement ne tient plus rien ne
voit plus rien et laisse s'installer le
désordre à tous les étages de la société
c'est un peu l'opposé d'une folie qui
accepte pour vous quand vous l'entendez
non sombre et qu en tout cas y'a pas
assez de fermeté les pros gérald
darmanin n'a pas réussi à obtenir du
président de la république c'est dans
sack's est un ministre faible il n'a pas
réussi à obtenir de moyens et de
capacité à construire un édifice de la
sécurité publique dans notre pays vous
avez vous avez d'autres ministres
ivoiriens peuvent être non seulement
c'est très faible
et derrière il n'y a pas non plus je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure la volonté d'avoir
une chaîne pénale qui soit beaucoup plus
forte qui soit avec moins de laxisme
dans la justice
on en est où des créations de
de prison et deux places de prison on en
est où aujourd'hui de toutes ses
promesses qui ont été faites y en a pas
une de plus qui est sorti vous avez des
ministres qui se battent mieux et qu'ils
obtiennent plus de moyens vous savez
regarder croiser une bachelot elle
obtient des moyens pour la culture
elle arrive à se battre sans forcément
rouler les mécaniques comme gérald
darmanin et faire des grands discours
c'est facile à la sauce anglaise tant de
roselyne bachelot
je trouve qu'elle défend beaucoup plus
efficacement son périmètre que le gérald
darmanin de défendre selon gérald
darmanin lâche l'article 24 recul sur
l'article 24
il lâche les policiers quand ils
envoient city beau message policiers
vous l'avez entendu hier gérald darmanin
l'europe peut aller plus porte je
schématise un peu importe le numéro de
l'article
mais moi je veux des propositions pour
pour protéger les gens il en avait une
il en avait eu la proposition elle
venait de serre en bois ils ne sont pas
capables d'aller jusqu'au bout parce
qu'il ya une manifestation samedi
instrumentalisé par l'extrême gauche qui
a mal tourné alors il recule à ministre
de l'intérieur qui recule à ministre de
l'intérieur qui a peur de quelques
extrémistes qui ne veut pas enfermer les
black blocks et bien et à mr l'intérieur
qui n'est pas capable de gérer la
sécurité des français
moi vous pouvez me raconter dans tous
les sens je vois que les chiffres sont
là je vois que la situation se dégrade
et jori gérald darmanin fait des beaux
discours mais que derrière
malheureusement pour les français il ya
peu de résultats sur un autre sujet
sébastien chenu quoi qui seront
peut-être liés puisque maintenant on
parle de transférer l'arctique 24 dans
la loi séparatisme cette loi séparatisme
elle sera présenté mercredi prochain le
9 décembre en conseil des ministres vous
en avez vu les grandes lignes on en
connaît beaucoup est ce que c'est une
loi que vous nous à les soutenir
d'abord il ya un problème avec le titre
moi j'suis pas sûr qu'il faille parler
de séparatisme séparatisme et bien c'est
vivre séparés dans la société
moi je crois que nous n'avons pas
affaire à des gens qui veulent vivre
séparées les pas du tout on a affaire à
des gens qui veulent imposer un autre
modèle de société
donc à partir du moment où on n'est déjà
pas d'accord sur l'analyse sur le
constat suis pas sûr qu'on soit d'accord
sur les solutions
elle est faible cette loi qui portera le
nom qu'elle portera la réalité c'est que
si nous sommes en guerre contre l'islam
radical dans notre pays il faut se doter
de lois qui permettent de mener cette
guerre c'est à dire de lois d'exception
on peut parler de la déchéance de
nationalité mais quand je vois que le
gouvernement cale sur ce tout petit
article 24
quand on va devoir parler de déchéance
de nationalité pour un certain nombre
d'islamistes radicaux français par
exemple
je ne sais pas où ils vont être ils
voient que sous le tapis je dire il ya
ils se rendent à des propositions von
himmel nous en avons fait un certain
nombre nous en ferons nous continuerons
en fête pour tous avait par exemple vous
parlez de la déchéance de nationalité
c'est à dire éjecter les terroristes ou
présumés terroristes ou fichier est ce
qu'ils sont étrangers de notre
territoire
ceux qui ont la binationalité les
déchoir de la nationalité française et
les sortir du territoire ceux qui sont
français
les déchoir de la nationalité française
et les poursuivre pour ces existe à dire
dans le code pénal pour intelligence
avec l'ennemi ça fait partie d'une
batterie proposition fait râler mais les
mosquées salafistes
là aussi gérald darmanin combien de
mosquées salafistes fermé depuis qu'il
est arrivé
et depuis les grands discours sur la
avec la fameuse mosquée de pantin qui a
été bouclé pour six mois simplement
combien de mosquées salafistes fermé
combien d'arrivées illégales
de d'immigrés dans notre pays combien où
en sommes nous de la politique
migratoire le lien entre la politique
migratoire
et puis les attentats il est fait
aujourd'hui quels sont les résultats
oui mais surtout ça pendant une vision
d'ensemble parce que tout est lié
en réalité là encore j'attends de voir
ce que le gouvernement nous présentera
je crois qu'on sera assez loin du
résultat
la seule et donc vous devant la salle
est la seule la cia des petites
disposition c'est pareil nous on n'est
pas sectaires ce qui peut permettre même
si c'est un tout petit pas d'avancé on
le votera
mais la seule qui ait fait les bonnes
analyses et qui les réponses pour
protéger les français c'est marine le
pen est aujourd'hui les français s'en
aperçoive nous sommes déjà dans le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle un petit peu avant le
second tour il faut passer le 1er mai
nous nous sommes des gens raisonnables
précautionneux nous considérons que nous
avons fait les bonnes analyses depuis un
certain nombre d'années de l'état de
notre société
nous considérons que nous avons les
bonnes réponses nous considérons que ces
réponses elles sont parfois menées avec
succès dans d'autres pays
et nous disons aux français qu'
effectivement nous sommes eux le modèle
opposé à celui d' emmanuel macron qui a
été celui de la déconstruction du rang
aujourd'hui presque quatre ans de notre
pays de ses grands équilibres le droit
du travail la place de l'état les
réformes de société emmanuel macron a
déconstruit beaucoup de repères de notre
pays et n'a rien construit ça passe de
société liquide en permanence ce
fantasme de l'interchangeabilité qui là
où tout est interchangeable on doit
s'adapter sans arrêt changer de métier
changer de boulot changer de vie le
changer de repère pour prendre le
formidable train de la mondialisation
nous nous pensons que être ancré dans
son pays être formés avoir une famille
venir de quelque part ça a du sens
encore et c'est probablement la
meilleure réponse à la mondialisation
un mot sur la crise sanitaire est vrai
mais alors le gouvernement doit
présenter sa stratégie dans la semaine
qu'est ce que vous en attendez déjà est
ce que cette gestion jusqu'à présent
vous convient c'est elle est émaillée de
stratégie sur le vaccin champagne de
vaccination avant jeu juste avoir un mot
ce que nous sommes le 1er décembre c'est
la journée mondiale de lutte contre le
sida
moi je veux avoir un mot pour les
chercheurs mais aussi les malades qui
depuis trente ans se bat aussi pour
avoir un vaccin sans avoir le même
succès visiblement que les chercheurs
qui trouvent un vaccin sur le co vide
je salue et la recherche française je
pense qu'il faut davantage de moyens
pour la recherche française
on en manque cruellement et je peux pas
commencer et ceci sans avoir cette
pensée pour vous dire qu'on a
formellement chance sur le co vite que
sur les enjeux énergétiques c'est
formidable pour le vide de trouver un
vaccin
je dis que j'aimerais que ce soit
formidable également pour le sida qui
est une maladie qui continue à faire des
victimes
depuis 30 ans je ne vais rien d'autre
mais je vais y penser parce que je pas
qu'on oublie aujourd'hui on est le 1er
décembre c'est l'occasion de le rappeler
bon aujourd'hui la stratégie vaccinale
quelle est elle c'est une stratégie par
étapes
nous ne sommes pas opposés à partir du
moment où elle repose sur le volontariat
et à partir du moment où les
vaccinations sont gratuites mais
également partir du moment où on fait le
lien avec les collectivités locales avec
les mairies avec les départements avec
les régions parce que l'étape pas encore
une fois tout décidé d'en haut et se
dire qu'on va vacciner à la chaîne les
gens sans avoir créé ce partenariat avec
les collectivités donc gratuite et
volontariat partenariat et de questions
pour politique pour finir fabrice oui
alors les régionales on en parlait tout
à l'heure
vous êtes ait eu des lots de france
région si monsieur darmana vous serez
candidat ment c'est un peu tôt je pense
qu'il n'y a que moi qui vous intéresser
aux régionales aujourd'hui à les
français ils ont plutôt peur pour leur
santé
moi j'ai déjà dit j'avais envie de
prendre les commandes de cette région
parce que les hauts de france son impact
est peut-être encore plus difficilement
que les autres régions par les
politiques qui sont menées actuellement
sa liberté nouvelle macro c'est les
mêmes politiques ce sont les mêmes
politiques de dérégulation les mêmes
politiques de pleureuses éternel quand
des entreprises ferment alors qu'ils
sont à l'origine de ce qui conduit à la
fermeture de ces entreprises
donc moi je pense que parce que les
hauts de france subissent truelle mans
en matière de santé en matière de
sécurité en matière de
désindustrialisation et bien les
conséquences des politiques de ces
dirigeants là oui je pense qu'il faut un
changement n'a pas vu de changement
depuis que c'est xavier bertrand par
rapport à ce qui était la gestion
c'est ainsi qu'est ce qui fait que jean
luc hees qui fait que vous ne serez pas
candidat a baissé à ma famille politique
de désigner le candidat
donc moi mon je m'en remets par
discipline à ma famille politique se
désignera le candidat fin janvier au
moment où on y verra un peu plus clair
et de nouvelles manières au bas vous
savez nous avons des processus
démocratiques de désignation de nos
candidats qui sont prévue par nos
statuts moi je me soumets bien
volontiers mais il ya d'autres candidats
et qui pourrait évidemment équipe qui
propose la nature et qui pourraient être
désignés mais moi j'ai cette envie de
président de notre groupe mais ça aurait
pu être aussi un député ou un maire de
notre région ça pourrait être d'autre
candidat mais et moi je me soumettrai
bien volonté mais j'ai cette envie je
crois avoir suffisamment réfléchi à la
politique nous pourrions mener dans
cette région pour faire différemment ça
marche pas en ce qui concerne les
transports et les trains ça ne marche
pas en ce qui concerne la sécurité dans
les lycées
ça ne marche pas en ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement des entreprises
on peut faire autrement oui une autre
politique à mener c'est vrai qu'elle
sera très différente
il vient
nous en parler quand le temps de la
campagne côté onu merci beaucoup si
sébastien genest d'avoir été notre
invité on regarde la une du dauphiné
ce sont les stations de ski et oui
difficile pour les stations de ski qui
doivent attendre l'autorisation pour
ouvrir à nouveau leurs remontées
mécaniques c'est beaucoup d'emplois en
jeu oui voilà station la colère et
l'incompréhension à la une de votre
journal fabrice merci beaucoup
bienvenue en face aux sites au club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]